Genau, dann kommen wir noch zu den Dictionaries.
Zu den Dictionaries.
Und ihr könnt es so vorstellen wie ein Wörterbuch.
Also Dictionaries, das heißt ja auch schon, übersetzt Wörterbuch.
Und das ist so, wenn ihr jetzt euch ein Wörterbuch vorstellt, das besteht hier praktisch aus einer Liste von Wörtern.
Und dann zum jeden Wort ist eine Beschreibung dazu.
Das heißt, ihr habt praktisch einen Schlüssel, das wäre in diesem Fall eure Wort.
Und ein Value, das wäre dann praktisch der Wert, der zu dem Wort gehört, die Beschreibung.
Und das ist praktisch dann einfach so eine Sammlung von Schlüsselwertbahnen.
Und das ist eigentlich ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Konzept im Beifen.
Also das werdet ihr immer wieder verwenden, jetzt auch bei den Assignments.
Und die Kies, das ist ganz interessant bei Beifen, kann wirklich also ziemlich alles sein, es gibt ja schon ein paar Einschränkungen.
Aber zumindest von den Datentypen, die ihr bis jetzt gelernt habt, das könnt ihr, glaube ich, alles verwenden.
Das heißt, euer Schlüssel muss nicht ein Wort sein, das kann auch wirklich eine Zahl sein, es kann auch ein Boolean sein.
Also es ist sehr vielfältig.
Sehr wichtig im Dictionary ist aber, dass ihr praktisch immer nur zu jedem Schlüssel, also der Schlüssel kann nur einmal vorkommen.
Also ihr könnt nicht zweimal null, den Schlüssel null drin haben.
Der wird dann einfach sonst überschrieben.
Und wenn ihr da dann auch auf dem Schlüssel zugreift und der nicht existiert, dann bekommt ihr diesen Key.
Bevor ich das dann euch kurz in Code zeig, will ich dann noch kurz zwei wahre Beispiele, damit ich das besser vorstellen kann.
Zum einen eben, wie gesagt, dieses Wörterbuch.
Wie ihr seht, haben wir hier immer im Fett dieses Wortes, das wäre unser Schlüssel, nicht?
Und dann haben wir die Informationen zu diesem Schlüssel, das wäre unser Value, unser Wert.
Ein anderes gutes Beispiel wäre ein Spind.
Praktisch ein Spind, der hat hier euren Key nicht.
Praktisch er hat eine Spindnummer und einem Spind könnt ihr reinholen, was ihr wollt.
Natürlich bei Beifern ist es so, dass diese Spindnummer irgendwas sein kann.
Das muss nicht eine Zahl sein, das kann auch ein String sein, was das natürlich noch viel komplexer macht.
Aber auch cool.
Genau, und wie definiert man so ein Dictionary?
Es ist jetzt bisschen verwirrend, weil wir es gerade setz durchgemacht haben.
Und zwar ist so, die Dictionaries werden auch mit geschwungener Klammer gemacht.
Der große Unterschied sind diese Doppelpunkte hier.
Das heißt, wenn ihr geschwungene Klammer seht und ein Doppelpunkt, dann wisst ihr sofort, okay, das ist ein Dictionary, das ist kein Set.
Das ist komplett was anderes. Komplett nicht, aber.
Man verwendet halt anders.
Und das kann man eben so definieren.
Hier in diesem Fall haben wir halt die Immerzahlen als Keys, also Key, Doppelpunkt, Value, und dann können wir den Value reinholen.
Und das sind dann immer jetzt zusammengehörige Paare.
Wie ihr seht, das ist dann mal ein Beistrich dazwischen.
Zugreifen kann man dann einfach, hier haben wir den Dictionary definiert.
Man kann dann einfach mit eckigen Klammern, wie ihr das eh schon vom Index kennt,
statt dem Index nehmen wir jetzt aber einfach diesen Key her, praktisch das ist unser Schlüssel,
mit dem wir praktisch dann einen gewissen Value aus dem Dictionary herausholen.
Und da gibt es entweder das hier mit eckigen Klammern oder eben auch das Get, falls ihr es lieber ausschreiben möchtet.
Und das ist ein sehr starkes Dual, da kann man nämlich auch einfach einfügen oder verändern.
Das klingt am Anfang vielleicht verwirrend, das heißt, sagen wir mal, wir haben Stunes mit also an der Stelle Key 20,
haben und definieren da Lisa, in diesem Fall würde bei Stunes hier ein neuer Eintrag mit Key 20 und Value Lisa hinzugefügt werden.
Und hier in diesem Fall mit 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3 haben wir ja schon definiert, nicht?
Also das ist ja schon in unserem Dictionary drin, da steht im Moment Maria.
Jetzt falls das schon vorkommt, wird diese Wert Maria durch den neuen Wert einfach ersetzt.
Da wird euch kein Fehler geworfen und kein gar nix, das wird einfach gemacht, deshalb immer aufpassen da.
Also nochmal zur Wiederholung, das ist kein Index in diesem Fall, sondern einfach der Key, den ihr hier so definiert habt.
So, oder wenn ihr später noch mehr hinzufügen wollt, könnt ihr dann einfach da noch einen neuen Key definieren, mit der gleichen Variable hier.
Und wenn ihr praktisch eins löschen wollt, dann geht das da wieder mit diesem Delete Keyword hier, mit diesem Dell.
Zeig mal ganz kurz her, schauen wir mal, was ich da ein Beispiel habe.
Ja, hier in diesem Fall, weiter machen wir kurz so.
Also hier definieren wir unser Set einer, sag ich, Dictionary, wenn ich selber schon verwirrt.
Das heißt, wir haben hier dann praktisch drei Einträge drin, mit 123, Maria, 3, 1, Tim und 42 Max.
Und dann wollen wir aber noch mit Key 668 die Martina hinzufügen, dann ist das ohne weiteres möglich.
Wenn ich da jetzt zum Beispiel hier Maria reinschreib, geht das auch.
Also die Werte, die können natürlich doppelt vorkommen, nur die Keys, die sind einzigartig.
Also da, wenn der Schneim definiert worden ist, dann wird der überschrieben.
Also hier in diesem Fall wurde 131, Tim durch Maria ersetzt.
Und ich kann das natürlich auch löschen.
Jetzt haben wir eine von unseren 3 Marias da gelöscht, also wir hatten da 3 Marias drin und jetzt ist der Key 123 gelöscht worden.
Jetzt haben wir nur noch den 131, der wäre hier und den 668, der wäre hier.
Und natürlich, wenn man versucht, etwas zu löschen, was nicht existiert, dann bekommt er auch wieder einen Fehler geworfen.
Sehr viele geschwone Klammern.
Passt, dann werde ich da mal ein bisschen schneller sein, ja.
Genau, das schaut dann eben so aus, ob es da scheint, mein Code nicht zu funktionieren, meine Präsentation.
Genau, man kann natürlich auch alle Schlüssel von seinem Dictionary sich rausholen.
Das geht mit diesem Keystatement, das Gleiche geht mit dem Value auch.
Das heißt, das ist nicht eine Liste, das ist eine spezielle Art.
Und jetzt, wenn ich das students.keys mache.
Dann, das schaut so aus in der Liste, aber es ist nicht eine Liste, das ist ein Dickkeys-Objekt.
Scheint kompliziert zu sein, aber ihr könnt es ganz einfach in eine Liste umwandeln, einfach mit List.
Dann bekommt ihr eine Liste raus.
Und jetzt habt ihr praktisch alle Schlüssel, die praktisch im Dictionary gerade definiert sind.
Das Gleiche geht natürlich auch mit Values.
Da bekommt ihr die Values raus.
Und wenn ihr immer die Baare haben wollt, dann könnt ihr da Items nehmen.
Und dann habt ihr da praktisch so eine Liste aus Dupel, praktisch wo dann immer der Schlüssel drin ist und der Value.
Und das ist ganz cool, weil ihr da praktisch das Ganze in Vorschleifen verwenden könnt.
Das heißt, den Key könnt ihr dann in ein Laufvariabel reinhauen und den Value.
Und dann werden die innerhalb der Schleife praktisch immer wieder neu definiert.
Und so kann man praktisch über eine Liste iterieren und Sachen machen.
Genau.